a lathe turned spherical shapes out of
the wood
several blades move in sequence to form
the piece when a new length of wood
comes through the front blade moves in
once it backs away another set of blades
shapes the piece laterally before a
cutter blade separates it from the ride
the painted parts now go to a pad
printer an automated arm feeds the
painted parts to the printer which
stamps each piece with the non-toxic
paint a worker uses a table saw to
groove another set of painted parts the
custom-made jig ensures that the cut is
straight and even and that the blade
makes only a narrow and shallow groove
in the wood
the worker places the groove part on a
jig and bores a hole into the piece with
the drill
the Machine piece goes to another pad
printer the pad picks up paint from a
tray and transfers it to the wood this
process called Tampa graffia printer to
reproduce a design on an irregular
surface such as this wood piece
the printed parts dry at room
temperature as a last pad printer paints
two dots on the wood the face of the
animal racer slowly takes shape
this red colored powder is processed
rubber wood sawdust entirely recycled
from the machining operations a worker
fills molds with the reprocessed sawdust
and prepares them for casting
the Machine compresses the sawdust at a
dye and turns it into a solid and
compact material called plan wood a
worker starts assembling the plan wood
pieces to form the body of the racers
she applies a thin coat of non-toxic
formaldehyde-free glue and presses to
corresponding plan would be tsa's
together she removes the excess glue
with her finger before she hammers a
dowel into the assembled plan wood body
to finish the head of the racer she
inserts a felt piece into the groove
machined on top and presses the head
into the racers body using a pneumatic
press
[Music]
the worker then drives the axles through
holes in the plan wood assembly
she takes painted and pad printed wheels
and applies a drop of fast hardening
glue inside each wheel hub
she then hammers the wheels into the
axles
and takes the assemble toy to a
customized machine designed to press the
wheels firmly into the axles
this finished chicken racer is one of a
wide variety of rubberwood toys
manufactured with environment-friendly
processes and materials